well we're here on a Monday Brendon shot
on Monday I'm Callan I'm fresh off
Denver your hometown
you're welcome did you get I had a blast
I'm going to need the key to the city
back legged educated City back I never
have a bad time sold out every show
Thank You Deborah your mom and on me in
the front row gave him a shout out a
memo front row say something right now
and tell you something right now a sock
clop I saw Jay I saw what's-his-name
still here no Hebrews came Saturday
night we hung with himself
fantastic entire body with my handlers
we'll get him back on the podcast love
them uh and then anyway the point is
that he saw men you saw him at
macchesney I saw that football player on
that good guy you know how to Colorado
he stretched human skin over a bear he's
the biggest man on the planet and these
voices is he's got the deepest baritone
oils so manly dude let me call my
captain when I was he was a senior when
I was a sophomore I think yeah that says
me he's defensive tackle captain a team
when I say yeah he is so much more manly
than us
yeah oh is stupid well dude I give you
cuz he is so aggressive I shook his hand
and I went I was like I didn't know what
he did I said I gotta ask you I said
well I go you're just are you just big
for no reason or what the [ __ ] and he
goes I fail since lighting Allen six
years I was like oh I got to sit out
that he sat me down this is going to
sound silly but he was the center and a
right guard center or whatever and he
was talking about how calling plays and
how complicated football is centered
shoulder than one I wish I had
instagrammed it he showed me one play
just how he would like when he'd come to
the line and reading about idols
dude it was so complicated show me all
of geometry it's math anybody who and
for me as a very casual football fan
when you see football on that level it's
such an intricate Deeks portal Mike so
when he's watching that field he's
seeing I'm sure you're the same way you
guys are watching it you're watching a
completely different games and did like
me I don't even know anything about it
Matt remarried so he was the setter
what's crazy about Matt is he was a
defensive tackle in college and they
moved in the offensive line to have a
better shot the NFL right but he adapted
Lee played Sixers and NFL crazy
she's wood nuts she's a freak athlete
probably used to yeah
it so when the center gets down and he
said you know the the quarterback say
usual pointed out one of the line
bicycles 52 you know 52 that means you
stats that's we start you the protection
from that make sense right very
intricate yes intricately short so at
the end slide left slide right man zone
like there's at all have enough but the
center's like he's basically like the
coordinator for Dauphin which I didn't
know so the center in a way almost has
to be the smartest guy along with a
quarterback on the field just senders
are super so smart they're them in the
quarterback they you know they're like
your avatar in the horse yeah do you
know have the horse after me go that's
Center in the quarterback he gave you a
nice compliment off air which he said
that you should 100% have played in the
NFL and the only reason that you didn't
was because you got started late and it
hurt you with Scouts and he said you had
all the talent and all the knowledge
that consider no helmet I don't know you
didn't tell I think it because we were
talking about football news I got it was
we were he was talking about how he gets
these young guys ready in his gym for
four dudes duty yes you're great I think
called six zero zero zero six strength
or some like done yeah I'm not sure Matt
knows his [ __ ] man you're talking you
know he was a captain of you know some
gnarly dude and we were scared he's only
guys we're scared okay yeah I don't let
you talk about new timeout dudes like
we're all big dude how work for guys
yeah everyone's good math here is you
man he's a silverback silverback he's
just over bad you beat his chest right
now you got this you got dressed you can
see it you can see these everybody's
done I'll be both of our bikes you will
just keep it at your house is cool it's
cool oh yeah that's a nice guy he liked
what I was making him laugh a lot on the
radio show and as I left he grabbed me
in one of his paws and pulled my body
into his body and I disappeared for a
second and he was just excited to add me
and he kind of grabbed me and I went I
made him noise oh yeah like that no
monster yeah hopefully he says Jim's
doing well
yeah radio show he's always a
personality man he's great he's great
he's a lot of fun now you need going
that if you're listening this [ __ ] I'm
sure you need going into Boulder and
rally them boys up
that's right speech you know I could do
it together slap them around a little
bit both you slap around and I want to
be in the background going that's right
[ __ ] that's right yes well I see the
guy in the corner over there that look
cocky who schemes eyeballing me dude how
about it how about talk about pressure a
university chorale the until some people
got hurt at least to do this the it was
the strength coaches idea to take this
it was like a plastic device it was plat
like think of like around this big
Daleks biggest table and had two handles
on each end so one handle I Clos blonde
hair you can hold you do we would gather
around like freaking you know like I can
gladiator and one someone call someone
out and you would have to hold whoever
could rip it from the person one we do
that before our workout ham well someone
would be like you know Matt would call
out some monster so madness monster
before our entire workout we'd want
everyone stare and watch who would win
who and be like who would it was so it's
like a tug of war service because the
Lord but it was yet between two men and
we create like a human like basically
cage around them yeah and there you get
close we push him it was so intense and
so nerve-racking because you didn't know
when you were up in time not leaders
elite so some dude who'd like ah he
raised his hand and the coach Greg
training like who you want you're up you
something like you're up Lawrence
Vickers who you I'm like I got shot man
cuz but what you want you don't what you
didn't want to do was call it like a
weak link and I got [ __ ] you like no one
put up with it so you'd always call out
someone bigger than you were so trying
on you it was so intense you do I did
well never lost
never never lost never lost never a lot
you got Matt maddening no one what that
was i up day charlie
cool man you got you got those you got
this thin can apply our fingers but you
guys that's just with you choke so none
of that none of that none of the growth
hormone when you're in the womb way to
the old fingers would stay but if I
write in those write to the old palms
those you got old dick in those got dick
and nose and palms you got a big old
weird coms with shorty fingers now and I
love that you were in Denver though men
at last I want to get you good idea
about your mother and and aunt nubby I
got to tell you something right now
what's your mouth generally similar to
not use your next words very slowly you
need to understand a couple things and I
want to be like on any uh your mom and I
have the same what yeah now hold on
April relax bro hey bro relax first time
I mom I'll tell you this right now as I
as I turned I've been performing a long
time and in the front row I turned and I
saw this woman and I went those are some
high cheekbones your mother some emerald
emerald green eyes I don't know how old
your mother is I'm telling you right now
when she was in her 20s and 30s I
promise you she turned she stopped
trying I'll show you a picture that's a
hot I'll show you picture your jackoff
this and I believe that because I looked
at her and I looked at your cute on
another you got your on nubby and your
mom got me they got me a thinking you
understand hey John it's you shut up for
a second because she's closer to my age
and I'm gonna say this I'm gonna look at
you want to say it if I want to take
your mom
hey man hey bro I'm saying that human
beings the truth happens sometimes
my mom's a look and she's a liking to me
I'll go I might feel guilty a man I
might even say something like can't
believe doing this to my brother hey
like I feel like I'm back I'm not you
tell any more honest Tessa
she must answers yes yeah my boy oh he's
my boy hello you do man you imagine and
we're on vacation you just hear some
juice here some bulbs laughing hey come
on they're all I mom you just hear daddy
yeah Sarge not too much Woods
hey boy hey boy Oh Betty Barrett every
minute our boy is here bring it out I'm
just all kind of coffee's ready
I come out all sweaty yeah your mom's a
real time real target although half mass
I come out all sweaty with with [ __ ]
amen hey I need some gel from a [ __ ]
a your dad for something more real time
she's a real car guy hey do me a favor
give me some sound maybe some neosporin
cuz my back's all scratched up by that
Tomcat in there yeah ha I don't like to
know that your mom and I have any real
long hug yeah whatever she said give my
little Brainiac a kiss for me and I said
sure will
hey hold on to me for a while hey man
sorry
hey bro and you saw all CJ was there
haha
I saw Jack do you gives Matt tickets to
your show sprays um Matt Chesney he I
think he did come with Rick Lewis who's
also with with a girl what's her name
she wanted
Asian she's Korean she went to school
with you oh yes you had Overland she was
over she's great she said they have a
radio show 106 7 yes and some Rick Lou
is a great I love it with us and so we
had a blast man I love that right they
make it so easy we brought they're just
[ __ ] around making each other laugh
for a long time but they all came okay
you know you're doing your job when the
radio people come to your show that's
all flattering to me cuz I'm so stuck on
words we sold out but standing room only
all the way through from Thursday to
Saturday I love them yeah and a lot of
it thanks to the podcast now it's not a
theater now I don't sell out theaters in
Australia and I want I want you to know
I'm happy for you once again what does
that theater you saw that you got alive
so you got a live performance business
where you sell out theaters man I visit
for 10 minutes now we've already hashed
this we've been over this but I'm
telling you you being mind your P's and
Q's around me I'm sorry man I can sense
it's done for you a little bit sabotage
my show didn't get picked up can we can
we get in this yes so Brian if for those
of you that don't know remember he's
gonna have a spinoff from the Goldbergs
he shot it pilot and it went great
from and these are from people that I
know in the business one the hot Brian
himself not the show the show tested
ridiculous hired Nicole perks Ireland
Golders Brian tested as a character
Azam's you know playing himself tested
the highest in Kenya's of any character
maybe see the highest about that how
crazy okay is that I did everyone told
me and I used to tell Brian all the time
skin picks up man how you want to I'm
thinking how we spend this money what do
you want to do it's only gonna help
fighting the kid because I was gonna
make a million dollars after taxes that
would have been in my bank account after
taxes everybody think about that a
million dollars after taxes so we all I
mean I thought I was for sure's he
picked up finally died only think about
you know this business's tricky like
shut the [ __ ] up skin I would never I I
kept harassing like thank you
let's celebrate it's go dinner Ben's
like not doing me you never know what's
gonna happen not doing it now we dude
you tested the highest in 10 years it's
happening man let's figure out what we
want to do with the money just by us
fine kid helicopter and then a shopping
to get ready to finger will buy another
Bentley fuck'em and then
was it what night was that uh I had I
was with I was with Stevie he went to
the gym he went to get coffee and I went
I was going to go get a bite and I got
the call
who called you uh the the producers in
Adam Goldberg and Mark Furyk who go
lined up from your agent
no no they though they called me and
what they were just as bombed they were
like you know they put so much work in
with those guys so much a lot of women
also they evolved and everything wanted
and again I was like alright yeah that
that's right so how the gold was like
hey Brian how's it going man dude we
don't understand it we don't understand
it and unfortunately it just didn't get
picked up but you know what's funny
about me is I've been doing so long that
when the assistant called me I knew it
was a no when the assistant what do you
mean because the assistant she's got she
knows that it's better so what the
assistant does do hi Brian
I have Adam Goldberg and and Mark Furyk
and Doug Robinson for you
it's just that really yes I don't think
the music in her voice because the music
is to be like hey Brian how you doing on
somebody for you I got some good news
for you Adam when you hear honey draw
out their words like unfortunately you
know that's how people talk when it's
bad news and you right away now I'm such
a I'm so good that like oh so one of my
agent calls usually when it's bad news
it's always that it's always I can you
tell - and when you know it - yes is
it's this Brian and you're on
speakerphone
Brian guess what well now the text I get
call me bud call me if it's bad I'm
gonna get text let's get what's going on
nothing what what's up why you come back
but so what did Adam go bringing this
guy with us I do we just don't we would
like did they give you a explanation or
they don't have to see down they don't
even give those guys next time why now
the good news is the Goldbergs got
picked up for two more years that's huge
for them and probably for me it's great
is I don't think I'll do you think yeah
you have a job do you think by extending
goldbricks
two years they just didn't want your
show to compete with that see I've
always heard this stunt in this yeah
explain maybe I'm off outside so it was
in the business was very close to your
show and ABC yep they had these other
shows that were
or that the shot pilots they've been
waiting to put on and it's all about
time slots that's right and so there
might be what four spots maybe maybe
really for you and you got to wait for
one to open up yeah and since the
Goldbergs got extended two years well
that's not a spot that's right it's
basically like it did acquit to support
you basically trying to get that kicker
job those kickers around forever I'm
just waiting for that and here's what I
say look here's what I never open up
here's what I was thinking the whole
time okay that was so awesome Bergen
should this spin off I knew it was great
and but it takes place in the 90s okay
with little character right love but I
thought to myself hold on I'm doing
great on the Goldbergs which is taking
place in the 80s and that's a hit show
for ABC now there that said that's a hit
show [ __ ] now you're going to put
you're going to put the spin-off on
which is ten years later then you're
kicked on the goldberg yeah awful yeah
just it I didn't understand how they
were going to make that work I didn't
understand how they were going to
reconcile the two because it's almost
like there's always a danger that that
spin-off could take viewers from the
goal you know you don't want to mess
with your gold meg your golden goose
you know the goose is about that's
laying the golden egg so I just didn't
know where was gonna fit and that was my
that's why I was so quiet and I never
ever even thought about it because I was
like I don't see my instincts again I've
been doing this for 23 years now my
instincts are never really wrong like if
you see me quiet
ya know something's not good yeah if you
see me talking you know it's different
anyway I'm quiet anyway I'm Adam I don't
care if I get a yes I know I got to see
the check and I got to see that you know
and you know of course as you know do a
season do six episodes do 13 episodes
you're still waiting for that call
did they renew us today it never ends
never it never ends it never ends for us
you know you're you're you're on your
journey here with this business and you
know you're starting to understand that
you're killing it with this podcast
you're killing it with with we're
killing it with fire on k2 you of course
because your nature want more you're
you're developing this stand-up career
but you know you're you're also going to
have to contend with what's next
what are we going to do we mean you and
I have some plans put the belt that is
to your point out stuff I'm doing I'm
the captain of the ship
yeah I'm not waiting for ABC I'm sorry
Adam Goldberg and these guys go we
accept you we like it because I you know
I want to have some control of my
destination now t all all dabble in TV
I've you know I've taken a shot here and
there and sometimes doesn't work out
sometimes does but I'm not writing and
dining and firm playing well you and I
had a good idea for something and we're
going to make that ball that's the only
I told I was I called after you told me
I'd called Jack said hey wait for Brian
to tell you but shouting you picked up a
sue I've really upset my called your
wife on their still dude now called your
wife and then I told Jay I'm like [ __ ]
it sucks man I can't believe it and I
said the only light I see right now is
Brian's had this idea for a script for
us and now he can focus on that it's
right at least happen with that that's
right and it's up to bubby yeah who told
me yeah we got some stuff I also we got
some friends I want to set that up
already what was fun so again I'd rather
in some ways anyway we'll talk about it
but that that that wouldn't be fun at
all getting to shoot our own show yeah
you know what doesn't get through you
know what I wish I wish that you weren't
afraid
well I'm afraid yeah wish you weren't
afraid to do a show of man that that's
my that's my only concern I feel like
you're you're you're a little upset
right now I'll just like sting a little
what if let me don't get my children
idea and sure I did you got a minute
yeah do you mind if we cast more
handsome guy as the kid what are you
saying somebody younger yeah just a tad
that's the tad Frank Grillo was
torturing me yesterday about he was it
another white guy who called me right
away because he's always in your corner
man that dude is the best and Frank
Grillo is like he just kept dropping
things like dude well you got your new
show sorry
he just kept order we used the money
from your new [ __ ]
haha blows day how about him he got to
pick up two years for for Kingdom they
got billboards everywhere cancelled
cities fancy hey you got picked up you
got picked up billboards two years
that's worth crazy money for them I want
to go in the number lazy man and guess
what yeah Dave it's picture all over LA
right
I like flex with a mouth and they in the
USA in the you watching your feed they
have these huge things franchisor yeah
and you know much some fight song as you
know your boy fire yeah Frank and then
right away I go
that's show that cancer it's all about
it I can't believe I just said that I
mean it what I tell you yes a lot season
though it's over after this a good
season to yank them goddamn is because
Matt Hughes is on it right season but
Jonas I can dick on their flight correct
Nick Jonas - yes a gay a gay a fighter
yeah do we have any gate we need some we
have gay female fighters we don't know
of any male gay fighters I'm I'm looking
forward to that day I can't believe it's
not one we gotta get him on the pot I
have a couple suspicions of guys who
before guys you would know but you're
getting a bad story I wasn't out of now
first Matt don't be like that [ __ ] from
Survivor
you've seen that know where he outed the
girl she was like I'm getting this wrong
but he outer being I think was a trans
transgender person and he outed him or
her the opposite way it was like it's
not you transgender and I'm [ __ ]
woman or something like that and that's
how I rest the world opt out and he's
all and he got roasted so bad for it
he got destroyed yeah he what I like the
small campaign didn't go well now he's a
guy did not have honest mistake I have
coconut water lecture I was long
electrolyzed and that my feelings were
hurt you just threw the career by my
buddy RS who one survivor told me that
at one point they were on this island
and he was hunting for snails he was
looking for snakes and snails and he was
so [ __ ] hungry and they would give
him a vitamin c i think ii didn't get
scurvy if they had no food cheese at one
point he was cold wet and so hungry and
he played d1 basketball he's a great guy
and he said I just started to cry should
I put my hand of mine get a lot of space
in my head I was so miserable yeah
starting to cry nothing I couldn't boil
any more [ __ ] snails she was just so
different to you then that belly full of
snails when he was lucky
only oh it was the worst there's such a
bit he said oh and by the way it ain't
safe there's a lot of things hell yeah
others a lot big hunting for snake have
you ever seen uh like when you
unsurvivable is cure
like do they hooked up like so so am i
grow any protein I'll see you around
yeah I got senior weird
I got loaded on and off and it's full of
nutrients well I I've asked sometimes
they'll hung up I've heard but usually
you're too miserable and they're cameras
everywhere
there ain't a situation put me in the
world would be to miss autumn I would
agree with you on that I agree with you
on that I've been on my debt and she's
like oh I got still got to lie right
well gosh just got him live to him after
all let's roll the nutrients on him all
right
I got no water in my mouth I don't put
that Pierre mouth on this date for me
first oh yeah and by the way I'm about
to come dust hope you don't mind
sorry about that little dust poof came
out of my dog mouth is that a good news
add extra thirsty it's powder just out
of our um yeah Manitoba outing but in
the UFC there's a bunch of women like
just entourage who I would imagine she's
got her ass look imagine and I'm not
Haley and I'm not shaming it whatever
she's about I'm all afford she's such a
warrior such pioneer if in the new EA
Sports really game they could not create
a more lesbian looking character if they
tried she had shaved [ __ ] the
apocalyptic very very masculine tonight
masculine look yeah yeah like she and
that's gone frame I mean she's got she's
not unmuffled know there's a she's got
it's about as muscular as a young man
you all know down what lady Jung Jung
check looked like [ __ ] ariana grande
night story I like that she had a tan
she was our God look at [ __ ] I use
acontece it just because just on drugs
went the complete opposite and you want
to shut up tan and you know I'd yeah I
was feeling you Lana that night
well if since we got into fight talk I
mean I would you need to see the fights
all the fights and you called I think
you're five for five
yeah I call on that one yeah although
the one before we go into the one I was
audio I I wasn't right I was at wrong
but I should have been wrong was the
Eddie Alvarez doesn't
Eddie I rescued a lot boy did Dustin
look good not someone great Eddie do not
look good Eddie
you know he was on you know he's on the
back nine of you know the fight and
looked like it was over and you start
swinging for the fences
he taught Dustin a little bit and then
you know is a fun fight to watch but if
got someone been more composed and
picked a shot to have finished him in a
heartbeat yeah it looked like he was
gonna finish him than those illegal
knees which were very illegal and I
think went by herb going I'd to no
contest I don't think he heard my
warning I think herb was actually saving
his ass there cuz herb [ __ ] up to the
first knee was illegal the second Nene
was uber legally did nothing and then
you get that so to be a no contest a
super fight in other words it should
have been you lose by forfeiture by by
by panic you okay yeah yeah does support
a should get his win money she get don't
you know in the wind III would agree
with Eddie I was losing that fight Ike
I'd picked Eddie up I was too much for
you but boy you look great I was wrong
on that one he looks so good I know that
Jason Knight has Kelly right I'm just
going yeah that was a good fight first
of all those prelims those prelims we're
better than any main card this year that
any fight night this year those four
[ __ ] prelims if you miss those you
need go back in one I only sounded that
were light years better than the main
card they was so [ __ ] good I was like
oh my god you clean up I think if good
cuz of technique and all that I don't
know it was excited I'll figure
something like like James Vick this guy
James victim's [ __ ] I would see 7 1
UFC now
he looked so goddamn good he looked
amazing that chased Sherman who I've
trained with before which I just sent me
when I was watching fight the night and
that Rashad Coulter is Rashad Coulter us
the material pride not not at all he it
looked like the UFC went back about 10
years rain jumped in the cage there but
chase Sherman was recycled throughout he
thought so Jay Sherman kept taking his
leg so bad he was I could barely stand
he switched he looked so out of it he
looked exhausted and it went to the
second round the couch guy he didn't
survive he start throwing bombs and both
start throwing bombs chase was rock is
back and forth
Wow it was fight of the night they gave
performance
it Jason night Jason nights like the
redneck Diaz brother he's like a very
like country bumpkin his uh his his
whole easiest fans had the Confederate
flag well you know we're yeah this is
where he comes from it's not I don't
like to be a gear them explain pride
yeah and then Eddie ours does boy that
one sucks because that because that poor
a should that should be the biggest one
of his career he gets [ __ ] her teens
off right now man
and I love her he plucked up there he's
like and it's too much we're relying too
much on herb Dean on this so what should
we rely on there should be a committee
out cycle and then I heard we [ __ ] up
those were illegal whole time poor this
is a DQ on eighty hours you can't do
that right also the rule is to great
needs to be black and black and white
with points contact on the ground then
you saw the main card we sing a David
branch jock go fight [ __ ] awful awful
I'd rather watch my fight with unreal
offseason hundred times over that that
fight was so bad
ah hey branch promise that now he's back
in Emma Dave branch fan he's a World
Series
you know multi Division champion and
light heavyweight middleweight and he's
like ah this is because using the you
see before you got cut he's boring with
the pipe so his World Series names world
champion he's like I'm a new man I'm
back on bring the heat terrible
crazy but because he's just worried to
commit is it worried is it is it nerves
guilty jitters definitely on world sir
as a father you start fighting you see
ur fighting just uncharacteristically
cautiously what wall so that shock jock
oh yeah number nine middleweight in the
world better than any fighter he's ever
fought world series of fighting he's
right I'm not yeah he's I competed very
long number nine yeah so but you're
world champion
tweet of it so of course you can get him
Jaakko you know he didn't bring the
fight branch didn't bring the fight dr
lim control although he was bored of it
so that's what you get yeah they both
they that's the thing what it takes to
to [ __ ] tango it takes to to create a
boring-ass fight like Orlovsky water
fight was boring as [ __ ] yeah it was him
and me yeah there's two of us yeah so
once i make suddenly make it aside and
just do you both get in that wall dan
yep and then afraid is this was
education for me okay why because I've
been watching fighting for four years I
love the game
I've watched some of a lot of your
Rodriguez fights I've certainly seen
probably I've not only seen Frankie
Edgar live with against although and
everybody else that I've seen him you
know I probably never fight he's ever
had now I thought Yair Rodriguez was
going to beat Frankie and I and I said
Frankie's a wrestler and a boxer
primarily Owen
garrier is this ninja okay so to me I
was like yeah is the new blood it's
going to be a technique in a distance if
Frankie can't deal with and all that
stuff and then of course you realize you
realize well first of all Frankie's
greatness Frankie's maybe in my opinion
and I'm not saying this out - yeah yeah
I mean he's Mount Rushmore Frankie Edgar
does you have to put him top five
all-time fighters in UFC I would say
arguably he's that good to me I mean I
just think he said I really do he's out
there yeah this is also the case with
you know like up and Frankie's a Hall of
Famer no doubt yeah but this is exactly
what Frank you should have done - yeah
yeah sure this isn't to me so concise oh
yeah but it's like number two in the
world like I and I tweet this out - yeah
air will be champ he has and when he
enters a con like in my growing he's in
me a superstar not right now now rides
gonna be a huge [ __ ] star he just has
to look the the charisma system he has
all he has his style looking like he's
your next superstar yeah not now and now
that he's got out of it he's got the
grip he has everything yes he has the
Mexican fallen he speaks [ __ ] Spanish
object his first language up like a lot
like Cain doesn't like he has all the
tools but if you want to talk about
mishandling of a superstar there you go
out of all the 145 in the world named
the top five yeah he I think
matches up and probably beats a lot of
these top five guys except for Frank
Lampard it's like it was like one guy
and there where I would like just if I'm
the Eyres camp and I'm the USM like
let's commit
I would I would like a fight for y Jose
Aldo yeah max Holloway yeah
Conor McGregor yes all those those three
are better math to the right if you said
you said a long time ago you go the one
guy I don't want to see Conor McGregor
fight is Frank
Edgar because Frankie would have
probably done the same thing to anybody
including Conor McGregor and hires a
huge [ __ ] 145 and there's all this
hype and I love that but if you
sometimes when you see hype you got to
actually break it down look at it and
you look his record I go I don't see
who's the best diabetes he smoked on old
BJ Penn right before that time split
decisions decisions Bruce Leroy was a
super close what decision you know what
Frankie Edgar would do you he could
probably fight the last five guys he
fought all in the same night probably
the same goddamn tiny beetle then so
there's this - like not not yet man no
idea how you guys didn't break he said
that Frankie said a good day to be a
champion just not ready yet and I was so
interested but you have you gotta know
got a pass on this and I don't give them
a pass and I'm not being super judgment
I'm just saying you don't get a pass on
this because how many legit superstars
you see have not many we get this young
guy who has all the potential and I know
you want to fight Frank Edgar out two to
five time to fight Brock Lesnar they
wouldn't let me for good recourse
because you're a fighter to see that
right because fighters want to fight out
dire wants fight everyone so all right
they go whoa yeah your ass for this of
course he did yeah but you have a guy
who he's not ready let him build let him
build let me build his fan base now
because a lot of people they're new to
the UFC
they bought this pay-per-view what do
you think they think of yeah air he
didn't stand a chance in that fight he
got dismantled so now if I can take four
to five more fights to get him back to
where he was that in the public's eye so
it suits them it's ruining your you're
eating you're young you're eager to eat
even you're devouring your young it's
stupid yeah
and literally you look at the fellas
vision max Holloway that's a great fight
forum Jose Aldo great fight forum Lamas
great fight Cub Swanson great fight
[ __ ] John great [ __ ] fight Pettis
great fly everybody bear anybody but
[ __ ] Frankie Edgar everybody what are
they thinking why are they what will
they're not bro that's the [ __ ]
problem and a white this is all of them
this is already Emanuel this is the
wrestle they just don't know the [ __ ]
game that's what it is man white with
400 million dollars in bank Eglin sure
why not back to the day it'll be like
hold up [ __ ] no what are you doing
because Dana would have known better
Damon what know what Dana is a
mastermind what kind of stuff Joao Silva
with a never that may let this happen
Wow never these new guys yeah Frankie's
a star here I guess he is older ya get
all that yeah yeah your kid he could be
big we speak Spanish sure a lot of white
clad mismanagement classic no man today
and and and it's crazy crazy stones a
job and not but it's people though
because you talked about how Canelo
learned so much after that last fully
mayweather if he was 22 when he fought
Floyd miller.time a different thing
Floyd who's undefeated Canelo we know
they have a lot of spotlight at a time
in boxing it's a little different in MMA
it's just this is a tough one he's gonna
be fine
he's still gonna be champ but it's just
unit I don't see the benefit from now I
just don't and you know also you risk
getting like damage to your eye and I
just crazy [ __ ] like that [ __ ] yeah
it's it's it it can that back in [ __ ]
here we came in a fight it was it was a
straight-up beatdown yeah it was just
like oh [ __ ] you don't be shamed me the
same luck yeah yeah it's silly you just
saw a young kid with great heart like
you know and grit but it's like who
wants juice fun to watch of it here
he'll do great swag know what jujitsu
you talking so Gracie Pike penso grace
and give those at black belts out so
[ __ ] we try on a d1 right that
matchups terrible and and it's a bummer
it's just a bummer what else you got you
let me see let me see one thing the
other fights
maybe my I'm already about yeah yeah and
I thought like so and I called I want I
thought Marvel only because he's on such
a tear and stuff but like you said when
he get to hold you by the way Jamie
Amaya said this is my toughest fight I
mean he was on a dream of all did a
great job like a backpack yeah where I'm
like a backpack
did a good job of keeping him from you
know getting not getting submitted but
at the end of the day it was just
classic Demian Maia matter what you
impressive is it Demian Maia she's won
seven a row
I could ask my mom hey what do you think
David Meyers can do this next fight
every single but we know his game plan
there's not a person alive that knows
everybody that doesn't know exactly
what Damon will feel and for it still
can't stop Oh No how the [ __ ] is that
not marketing how the [ __ ] does it take
seven wins to get a title shot finally
and if I like stainless come on dingoes
you got it
stabbing wins and we know exactly what
he's going to do no there's no one else
ever in history OC besides always Gracie
till now till this case funny doing it
now he Brian Stann give Brian Stann so
so he does come on let's go tyron
woodley I'm ready for you you're not
ready for you you know and Tyron goes if
he thinks he's gonna he's gonna do to me
what he did to you know har they have it
because you know time to be Russell and
and Brian Stann got up and gave him a
hundred pound backpack he goes what's it
worth his backpack for a while
in fact and Brian jumped on his back at
me around Rocklin and house I you guys
get used to this because you're going to
be wearing I'm like a Mac now my friend
story would would Lee my different story
explain that uh morning as far as a
complete overall fighters better than
Maya in Woodley as far as like doing
everything like as a mixed martial
artist striking and I can put it
together how long he's been doing it
he's been a mixed martial artist for way
longer than both of them love but Jamie
Mayer I was grappling jujitsu best in
the world Woodley as far as wrestling
like isn't power it can be taught you
not taking Woodley down he's not taking
wasn't he's gonna have to pull guard
half guard like he did with Jorge and I
love when he did that I love when he
does that so his only hope is to get
Woodley on top of him getting under
pulling them into half guard and
sweeping him because he ain't taking
Woodley down they got taken was like a
different story I can wait tougher
matchup for him really I do not crazy at
the night oh boy yeah I need to think
about more but as soon as it as soon as
it was the fight with Dorothy as a tough
five point exactly because was he's not
hearing a peep out of his wrestling okay
and Danny Amaya will always say I'm not
doing jujitsu I'm doing MMA grappling
yes right I'm punching people into
position I'm getting all my I should be
working on is you know getting close
getting your under hook and pull on top
and if he pulls them on top of them what
then Damien he does the Damien what
Damon why he gets the half guard that
deep half Kearney son host in
it's [ __ ] we're chick have Bassem aware
[ __ ] happen to the best in the world he
gets there and he's so [ __ ] good at
right that's a tough matchup on this is
my thing in and again with Daniel or
maybe being you know the analyst and
Rogan they got an ik it's a great team
they were off on this on the commentary
and I'll tell Jo this to say they they
were like these are close rounds I'd oh
[ __ ] what close rounds are you referring
to I this was the clearest 30-27 I even
have it 30 26 went and for a lot of
years they don't know this is the issue
when the commentators sway an opinion
people go all not there he's right man
Mazal ball did more damage on the feet
no he didn't what one is on the feet for
maybe two minutes he didn't really do
any damage
they were third rounding later he
managed odd not really when you have
someone's back that is as dumb as a
position as anything in the Octagon
mount it side control half guard when
you have someone's back and control
their back it is so [ __ ] down McClane
funny if the judges knew what they were
doing though some of those rounds are
actually ten eight rounds when you
control a man perform it that's if they
ran out that mentality around that first
round when at the very end like with 30
seconds left where he flips him over and
does that I don't give a [ __ ] what that
was he controlled for basically four
minutes before that control the man on
his back looking to finish the fight
name one instance when Dave Meyer was
about the offense in that fight never
supposed Ram should've been ten eight if
you actually know what the [ __ ] is going
on in the fight game so when I got game
is my score I think he has this in the
Buckeye I don't know I could see going
Jorge's way on the feet in what rulebook
are you referring to that fight was in
close no Jamie might this is his fight
inside plays a very safe he controlled
him the entire fight was in no danger
but he dominated the fight there was no
damage done because he's not looking to
punch anything he's just looking to
choke him out
why didn't know Horry Mazal had the
[ __ ] BJJ defense from Pluto it was
unbelievable i'ma be amazing the only
guy I think I mean when three
I mean three rounds and that's amazing
man amazing that much hats off to her
it's just a bad map where he trained
where he's down and 22 yeah yeah but um
yeah I did that side he probably
delivered he probably had a guy who got
all the time in training clear say 30 27
the only the first round was the one
like the very very any of the first
round is when I was like oh something's
gonna happen but that was that was it
yeah that's the last 20 seconds he shook
them up and did a little bit of grabbing
power damage I saw them yeah will you
tell my team I had a full body lock do
you know dominating that is and
grappling that's a nightmare this sorry
that's the worst thing you can get it's
like but this is this how you know that
was such a dominant round when Jorge
walked in out done I dented backstage
went what do we not want to have happen
finally you're taking down and gets my
back that's all I care about anything
else have fun cool within a minute Jack
Jack he's on his back like a goddamn
koala bear
all right Horry that's the first man the
second round what do we not want to have
happen we don't want to get under us
sweep us and get my back exactly other
than have fun you got it knocking [ __ ]
Gus is back all right sir God hi man
we're down two rounds some would say ten
eight but who knows I think I heard
Rogan and DC say you're winning I think
that's crazy
listen the stir around what do we not
want to have happen I don't want me to
get my back exactly just whatever you
doing first rounds don't do on third
round you got it cool exactly ACK how's
it end with him on the back now what do
we learn from this I can't stop him from
taking my kid I thought a me and my
friend exactly what I would hell like
what was the am eyes by backs Tamia my
the very best in the world
yeah and why I would have it just didn't
happen for whatever reason because you
know the both play safe wonderboy verse
Woodley I would love if well wonder why
we won that fight till you have wonder
boy who's the purest form of psyche
liking in the woods it's like we went
back to 1993 yep and then David light
comes out McGee and it's night to hoist
versus coy it's going back to 1991 and
you know I'm gonna be out if I have ume
is so [ __ ] stupid they probably
didn't pick up on that his I don't know
the game could have that poster tonight
all you do the exact copy of the night
93 poster but have Damien my and
wonderboy in there it'd be so sick they
don't have that imagination why don't
you work why don't you go be an
executive at TLC because I mean those
are good ideas from it from my marketing
so you want to jump
young-jun check out that that thing was
doing with the body triangle and he's on
his back before standing up yes so is it
better to be standing up the whole time
because you wouldn't you wouldn't go to
the ground right no long yeah you do you
see how my one to grab a leg to bring
him down yeah why is going to have way
more options if it hits the ground so
you don't want him saying but the thing
is Holman standing it's actually pretty
exhausting on the guy carrying it more
on my legs it's not you're tearing your
baby can I hug these by 185 you know
pounds and then they're hundred and
eight York and a hundred eight pound man
that's why he had him gets the cases
really some of the pressure right but in
people like God Mya's can be exhausted
he was tired but Maya was doing [ __ ]
Bali last when he was three years old
like that's that's his comfort zone he
didn't do that all healthy price that's
it literally is that cool I'll stay here
I'm with I'm what people understand is
he's dominating the fight the dominating
and not like so pure like I was born
that's fine
[ __ ] off he is literally dominating and
this is basketball he scored 50 points
Telugu scored zero figure it out yeah
goddamn it yep now I wanna if I a star
Josh I have a question before doing this
yeah I miss so bad now I know I went
before the does blow in the bathroom up
so we hurry it up I'm gonna secure it
please before you go away let's go do
some pistons fine now now now I'll say
this about you wanna Yin Youngjae Jack
young Josh and I wanna I wanna make say
but I want you to tell me what you think
of this she's a woman and her striking
her striking her level of striking is as
high as maybe anybody that's been in the
Octagon with the exception I guess if
guys like as a boy overall she's more
afraid than the innocent well there you
go so that's remarkable I was so blown
away I've never seen anyone be able to
the game plan I guess was to eat all her
jabs all I'm busy and all her leg kicks
in to land
keep moving forward but just a little
one she just wasn't even her bed wasn't
even snapping back I don't know if it
was that your honor I wasn't hitting her
hard
she looked like she was just fine after
five rounds of getting a walking shoe on
- yeah but walking straight into shot
after shot after shot her face didn't
look like it was torn up I was there I
was amazed but I don't know if yeah I'm
not that amazing I didn't look again the
commentating was how tough is just on
jaws I think she went over a lot of fans
here you know these girls are the strong
wings straw it's the night I'm always
other rowana you know she's not a
knockout artist he's to me you know
she's Bar None hands down the best
striker makes martial arts right now
amazing my fart Neil doesn't man-woman
doesn't matter she got to be she gets
seen people go well what about you know
the bullet Valentine you're talking
about her outside doctor on credentials
inside the Octagon as far as doing it
all put it together with technique you
guys the best yeah and then she has the
cake with the muy Thai world champ a
county called that yeah
should she close the gap on a takedown
defense and wrestling yes she's been
more of a handful but you know at
strawweight just on jaws you know she'll
and a few good shots she kept coming
forward with this straw weights like no
one's getting knocked out yeah if you
see a finish it might be a cut here
might be a submission but the strong
weights yeah so um for the UFC it's so
much better that you wanna young gent
check keeps winning because she's
starting to get gained in low momentum
like people start know who she's hiding
even though she's right all weight and
she's a killer
she's just a tiny fighter she's bigger I
locked her I'm watching her if I guys
let that jab and it's exciting to watch
her pinpoint accuracy and everything
else about her she know and I will say
this to men I would say this about you
Lana I'm on the you on a train now she's
the greatest female fighter yes he's
ever had that's completely lame if
anyone else wants to argue with me
compare her competition to Rhonda's
Misha yeah Gina Carano yeah look at who
she's fought yeah if you stack the
competition up granted it's 2017
of course you can be more competition
but okay whatever just look at the legit
people she's face and how many times
she's defend the belt and the way she's
doing it and Simon closed and she's in
there for 25 minutes
destroying the girls about 16 second
submission real quick not 30 seconds
here not this
she's completely dismantling them in
five rounds yeah she's out class in all
these girls in five rounds she had some
close fights with Claudia deja all that
but still helped toughest [ __ ]
Claudia yeah but still I literally think
she is the best women's mixed martial
artist of all time yeah I don't know how
these women like Claudia Dahlia and I'm
gonna add that muscular they're just so
thick and strong it's with trap you look
at you on a low you know look there's
not a lot of I don't know what's out
there you know they're gonna do the new
the new featherweight division right 125
125 so you wanna can go there next
hopefully they can build up a star there
so she can have the you know cross
pollinate there and become even more of
a star but in general you look at strong
weak there's not a lot going on there
now you got michelle yacht um so you got
uh rose by next yeah here's what I
here's what I think that with someone
like Jessica and drama is that her
ability to whether her ability or
whether that kind of like punishment and
close in and just start swinging will
probably probably the reason she's got
high ranking will probably work against
everybody most girls that I aren't at
that world-class level right she lands
one of those it's gay that's right so
someone like Rose namajunas who's great
is going to have to rely on her you get
to on taking her back or something and
yeah just to be in trouble with rose on
the gun yeah but you look at that
there's not a whole lot going on and
strong weights like Guillen's clean that
division Alex you should probably 10
times Jim I don't see anyone close to me
now it you know maybe Claudia today's up
to do that for a third time but no one
will see I guess but she has to man you
wanna look to me he's an extreme then
may vet
steep is like I have zero respect for
JDF as soon as I touch in this fight
though crazy walked through yeah and so
as a heavyweight like um it seems that
junior looks so good against been robbed
well but he was when he was circling out
his hands were open like he wasn't
protecting his face that's it that's how
JD s I don't care about that I'm more
worried that you know JD has had those
wars with Kane took it out of him he
takes all that time off then he loses
doused Rover and gets knocked out then
he fights Ben Rothko who's the perfect
fight for him he doesn't get touched
yeah and then you have to fight steep a
who I thought beat you the first time
he's only gotten better as more
confidence they fight him again yeah and
ski base camp knew like we just thought
this just walk him down walk him down
and punch him right but when you say
walk him down you're talking about a guy
who hits like you're talking about a
giant man who's he never on fire did he
nearly fired he didn't and and I don't
know I think confidence or exam used a
little Tintin I just think genius time
is over like there's there's runs
everyone has the runs JDS run is over
it's just what it is here's here's a
tricky one for you here's something for
you to chomp on is steeper the greatest
heavyweight of all time you look at his
records to be tough to argue that he's
not I think the fight first IPE who and
I don't think he's fighting anymore is I
can answer that only when I see him
fight Cain Velasquez you know came
taking time off your venues look look at
let's just go through steep base record
real quick here so he beat Roy Nelson he
beat Gabriel Gonzaga he beat Jones
Junior dos Santos even though they said
they'd get to junior he [ __ ] murked
mark cut most punches ever land in the
heavyweight fight
he murked Andrei Arlovski he merked for
Beast over doom he [ __ ] merked
Alistair Overeem he destroyed Juno
Santos
so just when he was a champ he has just
become champ
he beats Fabrice or dim sum regardless
best everyone team knocked him out in
his hometown in the first round fights
Alistair Overeem some would say the best
strike of all time touch the heavyweight
division he knocks him the [ __ ] I'm at
it down yep
then he fights Junior dos Santos some
say the best possible time you see he
knocks him I'm at an Asterix 2 at all
how weird is it there's one asterisk I
gotta add all of those guys you can say
Joe Santos Alistair Overeem Fabricio
Werdum even definitely Andrei Arlovski
and definitely mark on all of them are
past their prime
can you say that though for visa resume
you can't say it that's heavy weight
some of those I get out of some briefs
or doom when he won was the heavyweight
champion of the world here's the thing
about some recipes ever bid something
that happened there's something between
when he became and when and he beat he
beat up flying me up and I'm out and
also uh the tall giant guy um you know
um who you thought could be your last
fight Oh Travis Browne to [ __ ] so so all
that and I read you like something he
just looked you know to visor that he
looked don't a different fighter right
not really like body is there in Brazil
he rushes steep a steep a Knox mount
yeah most time that works people steep a
an ox amount yeah so I don't think it's
fair to go out for dooms over the hill
no but worried before that he [ __ ]
mur Travis Browne Murtagh gave Markham
and wait so now he's over the hill
because he rushed in the first round got
knocked out or is steep a that day might
be he might be and then we thought I was
over him else over him still not biggest
wins of his career yeah he keeps getting
and remember heavyweights the older they
get they aged like [ __ ] fine wine
well also other White's age like [ __ ]
steal a steep a really if you also look
at his camp second one we are in
American Top Team you got the best of
the best in a lot of ways steep it with
a full-time firefighter and it is
working out sillas and working at an
Ohio Cleveland Ohio where I there's no
one there's no a managed to fly to
Denver for training partners but they
have to train together all the time yeah
so he's got like this kind of like I
mean I'm sure it's team it gives him
credit he should
I'm sure it's team is great and those
guys know what they're doing but it's
it's I don't know what his training
partners like work was like Weidman who
go to New Jersey who worked with who
works with killers but his camp his boys
like he doesn't Hey [ __ ] be honest and
they said well I warned play saves lives
and works with his hands like a
blue-collar [ __ ] Prince I love that
guy
and how about his voice you know he
sounds a lot like who's not a lot of
like who's a friend of yours some cult
Oh Dalton Cody Oh Cody Cody Cody
Sullivan called Roy Donovan today I kind
of some boys that does that hey can i
mom
love it yes not everybody ah mom I love
you the best mom in the world
yeah he's just a crush on her Jesus
you're all man god you're aggressive I
need every Mother's Day mom
Oh Laura what for dare I can't run
through a wall I'm trying man a [ __ ]
Croatian he told you from Cleveland yeah
yeah easy on racial stuff oh wait
there's argument the best of all time
listen man the only fights make us
really is Kate but I don't know what
Kings doing you can't give me anyone
else and I'm like what about Franciscan
oh hey man I listen France is a scary
black guy I get it we're all scared of
black people that's why it's so much
hype I get that he's also ridiculously
muscular that's fine all black guys are
Nene I'm going to class up another steel
tub and he has a huge French hog all
right why do you say that
and why do you say I mean I would say if
he pulls his pants up bring up the
illustrator she''s we she filed yeah I
realized yes Patrick makes refile listen
I realized you see I realized he has
Pepe LePew in his pants that's all fine
and dandy and he's a big skirt by day in
rocks people he's an amazing looking
human he's great he's beat Wow again
this is this very similar Yair case here
who's the best guy he's beat Angelica
and how far past his prime is Andre
laughs yeah
48:40 and clip Andre he's gonna scream
here's a phase right before that okay
Dean Anthony Hamilton yeah for that he
beat
Boyan mochiko package before that he
beat Curtis blades for that he beat
Louis and the really pronounced Lewis on
Kiki and before that he beat Louis on a
leaky and then look again lekha
but and again he's going to be in the
UFC heavyweight is completely full of
dinosaurs he's going to be a top fiver
96 and I might be five I know what the
[ __ ] is that the hype on this guy is
insane
I get he's a scary black guy and he
knocks people out he named one really
good grappler his face say well if the
Hamilton College [ __ ] you I'm talking
about like a steep am talking about a
cane yeah I'm talking about a dude who's
not gonna sit there and trades where I'm
like a sweater and
get him on the ground and all that
muscle has got to be fed tell you guys
we've seen this before I don't sound
like I'm hey Don nice don't by the
hydrangeas I know how this game works e
you talking about you know about Chicago
he's Cheick Kongo yeah we in other words
hey check honking he's very very
muscular check Andre see what Kane did
to check on me when he had [ __ ] two
flights under his belt
yeah clip we do now one mount yeah
that's what happens that's something and
also the other a little bit of red flag
he moved from France to Vegas you don't
get serious about his training
hey wrestle in France no hmm and I hate
tell you they should Vegas anymore no
mmm me and grandpa Frank Mayer the
[ __ ] William Roy Nelson he said if
you want jumpin in Floyd Mayweather's
camp go ahead the [ __ ] in Vegas these
days right yup in California New Jersey
New York of Florida I said other nights
can be tough over at the black zillions
already jazzed Albuquerque yeah
the Vegas I'm a whoo the place trained
in Vegas hmm curls yes ah well just Hank
this game a the fight game and food
we're not saying he's not going to be a
[ __ ] superstrut well I'm saying right
now people OC Friends of CP what [ __ ]
who why would Steve they take that fight
right you just beat legends after
legends let's get the new guy we just
beat let's get Chan Khong he was brain
knock them all out yeah put them on
Kamali finish all up right away with one
holy guy your dad was steep a I'm sorry
I didn't fish was
JDS and actually won that fight he just
comes in two back that ain't no respect
no it's gonna be anything worse as if I
was right come on man you know I can
punch yeah I get that check this up
what's up yes ting [ __ ] sakes broke let
me warm up for a second I get Mac I'm
punching a great fight night well yeah
that's great little CI going buddy wait
Oklahoma this [ __ ] we are in Oklahoma
beautiful I'm taking a lot of summer off
buddy are you really yeah
I'm gonna be the element boxer I gotta
tell him up gotta lick my wounds you
took someone often telling me to film it
yeah sure did actually now I hate you
don't get me shooting you don't spin off
yeah but no cuz see the thing is I was
no because I was thinking about you even
wrote me a small role and take the
summer off on a voluntary I want to
monetary that's not gonna tell you no
you say yes I don't know it's gonna
happen not that much more that much
money after time selling out every
season across whoever hits turn upon see
I would have been Brene are being how
different managers don't revenge on that
happen so don't call here's the thing um
yeah it was it's only money and more
Fame no it's not big deal you don't have
any fear I'll get another spin only
build my new ruling frozen entirely yeah
it's not a big deal that phone call that
was the funk lately wait for your entire
life
what for 23 years in Lausanne I said to
my wife I go if this happens it'll be
one of the biggest goals that I'll be
able to scratch off look at me
the biggest now that I'm talking about
it trying to get sad again
so I've been you know well I think I was
fine coming in here and now my heart's
feeling a little heavy it should though
I need some helium balloons from a heart
somebody hey you know what though I see
what I don't want that like I love when
you're yes the best I goes leave me my
feelings are [ __ ] hurt and I wasn't
part of it also when Myesha that I was
even picked up me and picked up I was
[ __ ] sad man I think it's fine to be
like I I'm not paying a fine you as a
after as a man and you should go into
hiding yeah and like you're going on a
bender like Andy Dick and will give in
to that sure I'm not saying that but I'm
saying like to [ __ ] yeah man this
[ __ ] sucks
well here's the thing that the problem
is this that when you've been doing so
long and when your heart has been they
when they've taken your heart out of
your body and then they what they do is
they stomp on a dead hound veal and you
bread it when they pound your heart they
bread it and then they pour salt on it
so nothing will ever grow again with
some hot sauce and I put some hot sauce
so nothing else will go under they
radiate it you're a good out so now it's
you don't recognize it but it's this
long flat thing and they put it back as
you go channeling you don't feel
anything yeah you don't feel anymore
that's good well see gee I don't how
feeling and I'm being serious when when
I say that I'm 100% over it's why y'all
come out a little bit no listening
listening it's not I can't help it I uh
I move
none I'm actually writing a lot of new
[ __ ] and I'm just moving on I because
should I have to date I thought you and
me suicidal and I sing about all the
stuff will you ever do for me
well I'm gonna go ahead and kiss all the
hookers and eggs I know hold on all that
hey hey hey if you're listening this
Vegas VIP good shuttle dock is my wife
because my wife says what are you doing
with those that I've had I'm sad
no no not hard not the whole time I
didn't know I was crying any
presentative to me I I thought you said
it was okay you know doing let's cook up
sister that's the only way you get away
with it you start crying god I've been
so sad well my friend got caught like
with two girls he was shooting fuse with
two girls
what he's dating - well done and he's a
pleasure
the girl comes to his thing she goes
what are you doing with are you seeing
so that's not because no and all sudden
he sees her she comes around they got
together she was really anything as well
I guess I'm a dick now and then he comes
run off he got out of it by going i i'm
just i have trouble connecting with
people he got really vulnerable and
stuff like that because he kind of I
used is like I need you to help me
connect and sure enough he went right
back to having sex both him oh let's see
though I think that at the end of the
day he was like I know I got caught
it'll figure this out
good lord Terrace and conviction sir
and for what it's worth Brian I was
actually really bummed out to when I
found out thank you but I thought on
Instagram when you posted it so yeah oh
that's first I thought we post that
video video yeah I had no idea so it is
what it is all right credit vents Steve
Harvey you sent on a memo to his staff
to see this no oh oh this is good then
so he sent out a memo to his staff that
worked in the Chicago studio and for the
fifth season that they were going into
he said I'll show you what he actually
wrote please read actual memo because I
saw so to it I'm like this is a joke
good morning everyone welcome back I'd
like you to review and hear the
following notes and rules for season
five of my talk show
there will be no meetings in my dressing
room no stopping by or popping in no one
do not come to my dressing room unless
invited do not open my dressing room if
you open my door expect to be removed
my security team will stop everyone's
been standing at my door who have intend
to see or speak to me I
all the ambushing to stop now that
includes TV staff you must schedule an
appointment I have taken advantage of by
my bulimia policy in the past this ends
now no more do not approach me while I'm
in the makeup chair unless I ask to
speak with you directly other knock or
use the doorbell I am seeking more free
time for me throughout the day
do not wait in the hallway to speak to
me I hate being ambushed please make an
appointment I promise you I will not
entertain you in the hallway and do not
attempt to walk with me if you are
reading this yes I mean you everyone do
not take offense to the new way of doing
business it is for the good of my
personal life and enjoyment
thank you all Steve Harvey I I'm going
to go on record as saying that I
understand it and I'm going to go on
record as saying that may be very direct
but it's very honest and I I think that
when you're Steve Harvey and you have
everyone wanting to piece you you start
to lose your mind and I think he might
be trying to save his literal mind this
is so funny my brother sent me this now
what you're gonna think I'm an [ __ ]
but I understand it at a small scale I
can understand you but you guys are
dicks
blah blah no I told my body go I get it
to the point where if you're trying to
get someone you're singing about a
project you're thinking about a battery
steam out this and people are cause you
stopping here and yeah energy this and
your let's get back that matter your
health it's just you can't harder to get
things done I can only a met I mean I'm
not a celebrity by any means Steve
Harvey and you're you're taught you're
your own talk showing you this go on you
send out theater stuff like that so I'm
not is it a duty of Centrum Emma I don't
know it must be a real problem if he has
to be this clear in personality he the
kind of guy who and I've heard this from
he's also he's very open he's a very
very open and he's a comedian so Steve
Harvey is his whole life has been
available and and he's a he's a gue
garius man who people like and they see
him they smile they want to talk to him
no human being especially as you get to
a certain age can deal with that kind of
constant human onslaught and energy you
will stop being effective as what you do
and you get unhappy because nobody is
made to have people without any kind of
warning come up and hit you with
problems all day because let me tell you
something with Steve when there
and they want something or the hitting
with a problem he's also put out fires
oh because and well I've heard he's
actually good dude yes he's trying to
put at least he's gonna help you yes so
that's just Adams he's asking for you to
make an appointment he's asking you to
give him so you're organized yes he's
happy to ask you to see most people like
out certain last Adam like [ __ ] you like
doing stuff how does a comp is that you
know like you gotta figure stuff out
like this is the way to do it this memo
the mem was a little harsh but I go back
thing and I if I was Steve Harvey it
must been so bad was like dude for reset
to season five I have to ask this yeah
I'm also in writing I better pay hey
what do you like hate being ambushed
please make an appointment
that's that must be really bad do not
wait in the hallway to speak to me I get
it the minute you open the door yeah
what's up that it can get crazy of no
break you're on a break and I think
that's a man doing whatever he can to
keep himself saying now it's different
if you see like I don't know if you've
seen know what I think Jason to me
Justin Bieber's demands he was in India
of doing a show you saw the demands it's
so insane that's a diva like he wanted
there has to be a bowling alley movie
theater within a mile there has to be
coconut waters this temperature there
has to be he's Eminem's actually this
star bus there this this like I fight it
right over G yeah and it's a release it
like was what this [ __ ] asked
for be like he did the same thing to us
so whatever that's his thing that's fine
that's a diva with Steve Harvey he's not
asking for all pink eminence or some
face he's asking for space so he can get
his job and he's being direct about it
and I don't know how else you would do
it believe it or not I don't know
because you again it's like the rule
with the hands down on the osteon that
it's very gray
so people are constant gonna play in
this weird field if they make it black
and white you know where to go and I
believe isn't a bad black and white he's
gonna take an advantage of Iranian
policy I agree yeah he must it must been
so bad and black people don't use inside
voices where he is just like holy [ __ ]
man well out of chill if you look at
guys like Tom Cruise and I've had a
limited exposure who people who have
worked with people like that very
intimately they are a machine so when
they say yes or no
if they say yes an entire industry moves
in that direction and probably without
exaggeration 2,000 people get paid
because he said yes
okay I'm Cruz but I'd love to work for
class-a more right not here but so what
happens with those guys is they they
just if they don't have a shield or some
kind of a measuring stick or something
to keep someone to filter the bulls you
would go you would go crazy you would go
[ __ ] crazy sign up signs all day
there you go what do you think chin do
you think we're gonna go that angle do
you think we're gonna roast them I
didn't know what any was gonna go but
after I saw his interview cooking on
that face value it just sounds it's so
harsh yeah sound black and white it's so
so harsh but then I saw like a
transcript of his interview with someone
from Entertainment Tonight and he was
saying how like he couldn't even go into
his dressing room just to eat a meal
without someone popping in it and saying
like where's my friend can you get him
an autograph or take a picture he would
never have those moments so I get it it
[ __ ] up good performance because you
literally have no down time together
side and believe me people say can you
come take a picture and they come here
all the trust me I look I love people
and I got a big fuse for it and on my
small small level but happens all the
time and I and I'm yeah I'm a guy who
can deal with it I do but even for me
who has an endless capacity for that
that can get it's just you're human
being you know it's just too much even
the rosin wakame storing the same guy
keep going this wool what do you mean
man like I'm trying to become serious my
friends I took the picture yeah a
conversation what else Ronnie Hogan's
credit he's all nothing I just want you
to it's over brother
it's over me I listen I'm literally
trying to have a conversation my friend
here I'm not trying to be a dick but we
good is why Junior's right hanging out
what are you doing with no man I'm I did
a show I'm just running conversation
here and I'm like not and I went that's
a ruffian it's not though
no it's not that guy there's a ton of
people I got jobs you're coming back to
keep yours they will take advantage of
ya and they're in your face they don't
get it it's like do you know yeah I've
seen him after he's very good at
shutting that [ __ ] down cuz it's great
and this is that where he works
so it's tougher you know if you're out
in public and you don't really help gate
for him you kind of expect people to
come up to you but when you're at work
and they're constantly you know bringing
people into your dressing
you also gets physically grabbed a lot
so if you're me they don't do that when
I'm with you so interesting little Gary
but I get grabbed like uh and it's fine
they take this young guys they're drunk
they love What's Up B sometimes but I'll
hit your chest I'll hit you they grab it
they just love you but that's just it's
just energy that you have to deal with
that and again nobody loves it more than
me nobody loves I love all of it you
know they're all great it's all to grab
no but I get grabbed because I'm no
touch as long as guys are bigger than I
they just they just love you they just
you know so it's all right but it's its
energy its energy can is that all the
time will you deal with your Steve
Harvey all the time I first heard this
my brother syndrome like got a little
brutal that I thought about like I kind
of get it by her on Howard Stern were
hear it read that off like god that
[ __ ] there's a harsh email I don't
fight send to everyone in my office and
I thought about more I'm like and then
again I heard the interview and you
listen to me like he got he must be like
dude I just I can't do this I can't be a
family and I can't do my stand-up like
I'm exhaust and he might have written
that when he was feeling like he was
gonna go crazy might have just written
and be like I am seeking more free time
for me throughout the day that's allowed
that's fair I like acting off with
Oliver he said he's not even apologizing
for it no he said this is how I feel and
good it sounds I could awarded it
differently and good feels like this is
how I know yeah me farm was this Bravo I
hope they get a brought that guy Andy
any Co any Cohen Cohen she made some
sort of remark about like oh he put a
doorbell on his dressing room now to
make fun of the whole Steve Harvey thing
so
of all people I think he would be more
any cut well any cones it is he kind of
like any color so any tone is making fun
of Steve Harvey saying like he's putting
a Andy Cohen's putting a door bell on
his dressing room on Steve Harvey's
dresser know for his own for just a big
yeah that's like I mean any come with
their photo for far cry from [ __ ]
Steve Harvey but any cut you know any
Cohen he's brilliant what he does he's
hosting oh he hosts all this shows he
hosted about the Real Housewives
after-show and then he's doing a new
game show I think on NBC stuff like that
so yeah he does his hosting something
he's no Steve Harvey I don't think
people are knocking down the door to get
in to see anything I barely different
barely know he is
sons you dick so hard yeah yeah I'm not
by my oh no I'm a little not texting
around all right now you you like yeah
you know you know the Abby the [ __ ]
sure Abby of course we both had yeah
what have you even let first got hit
with a young lady by a young lady oh
it's interesting by young Lee you would
definitely know everyone would know I
went to you ever Mon lived there you
never put a knit cap or dance I'm gonna
be first of all I never got more
manhandled in my lighter arrows to that
you're a big beautiful piece of meat all
youth oz a [ __ ] prime you lady don't
way friend material because you are with
your ears and your UFC pedigree and for
a man to date you you'd be his boyfriend
and show you off mmm-hmm and you just be
the big old alpha male that giant just
and the bros the big alpha chimp that
walks in and he be like ribs and ii do
so he is first of all he is he can beat
everybody up in this room and there's
something about the way he holds me down
but i [ __ ] love this is so good and
and you would be like and I was straight
for 33 years until my partner break came
along and Frank came along Brian said I
accept you yeah and once I got his green
light and Brian kissed my mouth way
better
yeah Gobert the thing is is you know
Abby has their own show Andy coming out
now but they're trying to I don't know
I'm looking at the dudes like a
highlight of it last night I'm looking
at like but they're not playing the gang
go
that place is a [ __ ] gay icon it's
again that place is a monument it's a
gay Mecca
nobody's covered in mail come lovely
well the place is come walls come on
don't say that they just a lot of guys
don't have shirts and when they Dan this
[ __ ] Nabi I put that is the angle
they take on the show they make it like
an icon like well no man the gay things
the cool things like that's the Abby and
that's the angle well maybe maybe that
was a really girl and she was smoke show
and it I mean I didn't know I first
moved to LA I'm like yeah girl Abby oh I
did I'm like God isn't she wanted not
had a whole problem for everybody her
best friend was there she like he has a
table to be fun
in walks shoulders in walks hungry eyes
like a hungry uh oh [ __ ] for smoke show
of course you do
how's the cake analysis this is fun no
this is ground sweating handed the grab
me little tore my shirt not a big deal
do you should we just get out of like a
[ __ ] I'm sorry I'm losing page and I
just got [ __ ] ah yeah I am sick of
smacking dicks away from never tell you
I walked through a club primarily black
Club in London with Scary Spice every
tie at where she grabbed my hand
Scary Spice uh-huh she's a died oh my
god is she had died how long goes this
this was when she and her scary slide
brother yeah and she grabbed him by the
hand real serious but that's funny I've
ever seen in my life bro I'm good I've
ever seen I live she walked me through
this nightclub in in Mel why he'll be
because we were hanging out I was hanger
her and Baby Spice and uh dude guys were
grabbing her giant dudes were grabbing
her her till she was just her ass and
she was I get that [ __ ] off me a mother
died and she was just she didn't she
gave it back she gave it all right back
lower guys just when I was there and I
didn't give a [ __ ] about me she would
hold my hand
I never grabbing her wide and I was like
because she's sexy as hell and they were
all bro they were all do look at me
British black guys no one's listening so
Vermillion point three listen listen
yeah did scarce once a day I'm going to
be honest with you I wish I could say
yes and I know you tell the truth and
nothing having any answer is G and
release those Lipson I I wish I could
say yes you're alive to thought figured
even lying you're telling the truth well
I would and I want to lie about this and
I you know I don't lie about anything
but this is where I want to lie and and
I will say this that if I had pushed for
things I believe that it would have
happened anyway okay so but there was
there was energy between us there was
energy between us something was going to
happen but you know what at the end of
the day he is a she's a famous soccer
players bring her up when she was
younger please without Eddie Murphy
she's so amazing like I love her
and she's got a great personality and
she was so cool who she's dating
like I just know she looks better now
but when she was the only girl by
I was like am I really to my Lou she was
yeah she killed me she killed me that
English accent - oh dude she's laughing
I was just perfect
she was Percy's going through some
divorce or something with someone that
she was with because he was having sex
with the nanny as well and they had a
three-way and then someone broke the
rules and had the two-way without you
can't ruin a knee in our three-way which
is crazy
very hot Carrie hello you can bring that
in three-way you can't [ __ ] nanny in the
three-way if you're right girls not home
right she's got abs in that picture over
there by the way no she is let me see
this guy let me so come in for a sec
yeah that's the guy that's the nanny in
the middle well well she actually looks
good I saw the nanny doesn't really hear
I mean I had a little crazy here but
really I approve of all of him oh well
and why would you have her ask the
manager nanny you're already asking for
trouble because nobody wanted trouble
let me see this guy what's he do cuz I
this guy there's some sort of I don't
know what he's got you up here uh he's a
cute man he's cute he's got bad hello
Jim that rope chains terrible it's not
worth analyst rice tea but yeah but I
can I get away with wearing that that
rope I think so I want to start wearing
jewelry but I just they're having a
threesome with this nanny she comes I
get my testes balls-deep yeah you do
she's balls deep in the nanny she flips
out cuz yeah he is having sex with the
nanny without meldy of course and then
it just caused a ruckus of course that
happened of court you can't what are you
gonna do a we already [ __ ] let's not
do it now because the girls not watching
you know you let have done a good job -
right that's hot that's his nanny you're
out of your mind
if I walked in it's a marital that's
called a marital lie landmine as my
buddy said four boards being awesome
this is the thing if if like Mike if you
see if the roles reversed and I come oh
my girls like this is the new mani
it's a man it's just this dine Pete like
it looks like Christiano ruin all don't
like what this that's the [ __ ] mani
like it we can't both get at it well you
haven't got barely speak English get the
[ __ ] out it even said when you when you
was got a really hot trainer personal
trainer coming to your house cuz you got
money nah ain't happenin mad ain't
happenin no we have some teacher my kid
I swim hello lady hi [ __ ] hey old lady
jump that pool taking a shark these - my
buddy run some diabetes from Baywatch
elbow we doing but sure about you [ __ ]
you doing
who told you coming here my butcher my
buddy and his wife looking for nannies
they literally purposely were going to
all the pictures they're like too good
looking too good looking - we're gonna
this is good right in the middle let's
get with that skeletal skeletal
situation going on in the tummy let's go
let's go with that no I need a heavy set
yeah I can't be checking my hair I can't
be no I can't be worried about walking
out with my [ __ ] dragon breath in the
morning and probably a raging boner most
likely I'm an unmanned yeah I'm in my
undies I'm in my whitey tighties
I walk down the stairs I look like [ __ ]
I'm just trying to eat the Talking
Machine yeah I can't have some time
people cry for a while I started where
are we where's all right Mike I just
diksa yeah she's looking at you know I
used our Croson dick kind of fight with
my girl you like being mean I mean girls
upstairs baby still sleeping you're on
the job yes I'm paying yeah
you mind if I grind these beans you suck
my dick I don't provide sexual
harassment well no she would be she
would sign of concept for guy comes a
dark roast on a dick sucked every Monday
it that seems like everybody a.m. that's
a tough contract but all right when I
was only inside it I guess
look at that that's their girlfriend huh
well used to be yeah good for that guy
he's only doing what he had to do there
well it sounds like he's Mel B's idea
don't stick your finger in a cage if you
don't want to get bit what would you do
if your if your wife was like hey I
won't have a threesome with the nanny
I would probably I would go to Dana's
rodeo today this is dangerous I would
say all right yes but she's fired
I agree what the I can't have the nanny
first of all fire her first well I'll
see I'll have another verse first of all
I don't want my nanny being a goddamn
freak suck my dick
suck on your titties and watching our
kid she's often kind of [ __ ] up ahead
ready to open for this I might be so
she's fired
even if she's open for this discussion
you're fired when you
else for funerals but not so fast the
whole box before Brenda Henderson I
don't know it yet well what I'm just
saying yeah severance bag isn't seven
arias everybody's not my dick my
American dig wrapped in a [ __ ] red
ribbon hey what happens if your wife was
like he'll never threesome yeah you can
pick who I get to pick who would you
pick some random would you find so on
Instagram would you go to website would
you find an app I probably wouldn't do
any of it it's too much planning and I
wouldn't what if your wife was like babe
I know you're busy
let me deal with it I will pick three
girls yeah this Saturday night working a
hotel room I got that red glass nanny
watch the kids not a freak without a
regular house nanny going as [ __ ] I'm
already getting a little hard right now
but is your wife got picked up three
would you do it should I get a hotel
room
would I do it look at me how well do you
know a riskier oh you know me I'm super
me it's a risky road yeah and I hate
risk you know me I'm a I'm a real risk
I'm real safe hire a fighter right well
here's the end your wife goes there's
right so we pick this girl she's a ten
yeah her boyfriend once in though
well now now but she's a 10 she looks
like Mel B 10 years ago yeah now here's
the thing gotta see the boyfriend's dick
if heat works it's not a fix but there's
not a problem dad oh yeah hey Amanda
chef anything yourself oh good good good
add fun with that medium that I was dick
and I'm not over here with I'll be over
here with Jenn spice things up a little
bit then and then I'm gonna have to give
you a punishment for having sex with a
man other than myself
okay and if you dare to enjoy it we
watch your face the whole time whom
would still having problems his
interesting road to go down she'd been
out with an Affleck ended his marriage
to the add this have you seen his naming
this died off of a nanny and he goes
should we need to stop in Vegas we're on
a private jet we got something Vegas
yeah and did work he did hey Batman not
bad that Bruce Wayne like that was her
[ __ ] name what see again what do you
expect
he's famous as [ __ ] she's hot that
matter
a time all racing's down let's be let's
be real
she's way hotter than Jennifer Garner
let's be real you can't bring in a nanny
who's hotter than your girl in the
[ __ ] there's always somebody hotter
right you're you're my kid you're busy
you're getting older you're you're hairy
at time and you get this hairy
three-year-old hairy Harry Reid Harry's
like this all you don't drop your hair
your honor to jamas and you hit twenty
three-year-old girl comes in and she's
all decked up she's got nothing to do
but tan shave and workout and and she's
looking at you with them hungry eyes and
yeah Kathleen and your back and my duty
of Gotham City or gif do this and I'm
just there and I'm like whoops and then
all of a sudden my piece flops out of my
goddamn jeans by accident let's put them
and I'm like why does this guy have a
lonely look on his lip than any look I'm
like I don't know but he does look
lonely yeah he always got that same look
on his face he's so serious I feel like
he needs a hug relax brother yeah it's
all good man
big handsome Batman relax he's a big
boys and he's got a huge bone structure
like he said he does brother what a
goddamn Oscar a lot of the a meal I yeah
a lot of those a lot of actors I feel
like Johnny Depp at 54 still wearing
ribbons and beads and talking I dunno
yeah it just gets it gets a little bit
you know sad road I think that I think
so i think you get isolated I really
liked weird life Brad Pitt Tom Cruise
Johnny Depp Heather all not doing well
not do well and what happened was they
they know and and I think because you've
been treated like the King for so long
you get isolated you probably didn't
have time to forge the kind of
relationships that you know you do when
you're with nothing's real so that's all
right but you're also you constantly
playing someone else you're confident
when the lights are off you're in the
dark and take it from a guy who's 50 and
now getting older I swear to you when I
say this is a part of the reason this
show did you get perspective on life
like you you realize that celebrity or
whatever it is you realize that another
movie you realize that all that stuff
especially when you already have enough
money like these guys so so the
challenge if the work stops being a
challenge or the work stops being fun
then you're kind of left with that your
only option I guessed is to show up as
this actor in this world but you you
lose your it's just not I don't know
Johnny Depp I saw something on through
like six hundred million dollars oh he
got worse Ogden but yeah yeah no no he's
got drinking it's also to spending money
spent operate but it's also constantly
an attempt to look like [ __ ] Jack
Sparrow must be age long well I was
going to say look I don't always have to
look like a pirate I get it you love
Jack Sparrow
I love - screaming third one was [ __ ]
terrible he's down my face one and two
I'm all about it might be the best one
this fourth one with Benicio del Toro
it's amazing yeah I love all those why
do you constantly have to look like in
Tim Burton movie well I get it your
thing he's got two bandanas right I
don't know he's wearing two rope
necklaces there he's wearing another
rope necklace if you look under there
and then two other he's a lot of a lot
of jewelry i love done a lot of jewelry
everywhere and a lot of cigarette
smoking and and look it some people like
you love the others yeah yeah and I like
I wish I could wear something like that
I'll get laughed off the red carpet no I
mean look it's it's fine it's just a
little um my problem is I wonder when I
went on behind character yeah that
tomato there's makeup on his eyes too at
54 when you're wearing eyeliner at 54
and and eyeshadow I I asked the question
what's actually going on here
something's going on generally me like
I'm there's something when it's that
much work look what he's wearing for
that many look that necklace takes a lot
of work it just it's bouncing around and
making newark he traveled the [ __ ]
70s he's collecting ship yes look at
that like there's angrier clothes
there's no cover no shell got he's got
he's got the oysters work boy that's
poisoned another pufferfish down below
there is a goddamn silver dollar yep
there's a finger there's a human finger
if you look to the right they're hanging
it's it's from the Congo somewhere he's
got all kinds of [ __ ] on there and that
that takes that's just not comfortable
to wear so when you're 54 and you're not
comfortable and you're still working
hard to look that way I don't know what
the [ __ ] is going on that's all I'm
saying
something something else is going on
that's all and with us yet soon I agree
that's weird all sad do you guys give
passes to like rock stars I do that I've
even in their 50s absolute
yeah you go past with me the eyeliner on
your finger bono and your kiss I saw
bono at Nobu Wow
hey bro why are you wearing yellow
Oakley Wow and no boot idiot God it is
not o'clock in there he's on a day look
at me to get that and do the whole
Africa I get out I'm a [ __ ] one more
time long yeah why in the bloody hell
they were in those yelling and that's
all the cheap action unless you're
Steven Seagal cannot wear those the
legit question dude how weird it's a
legit question because again what were
you gonna glass imagine if I walk around
with yellow bullies on you'd like the
[ __ ] are you doing like I want to wear
these can't wear those right cuz you
know question ask you and I have friends
if I go hey excuse me what are you doing
what did waiter a hey other me what are
you doing man we gotta hang out stop or
my girl is my friends like you can't buy
did I ever tell you that when I got mad
tv I've got 26 years old I got I came
back to New York after nine months of
being on television okay this is 1996 I
couldn't have been happier with myself
and I was a celebrity I was an actor I
just want all I wanted was to come back
New York and I was like I wonder if I'm
gonna be recognized me so I'm fighting a
guy maybe I'm I got youth dreams you're
like I might be a might be famous oh
sorry miss is exciting so here I am on
TV I I had proved to myself that I at
least was good enough to be on TV
whether whatever and I couldn't like see
Jimmy Burke and I showed up in a kind
girl hat you know those hats the Kangol
hats it was turned backwards and I
looked good I decided I might be the
kind of guy who wears hats now I might
you know me you know me who could
fashion so you always yeah
but suddenly I'm like I'm gonna wear I'm
gonna wear a hat and I'm gonna work you
know I'm gonna spend some money on
clothes because I'm an actor now I might
get recognized so I show up in my
[ __ ] hat and I see all the guys from
New York and Jimmy Burke goes dude
[ __ ] dude I cannot [ __ ] I'm so
excited I'm so excited for you man we
got to grab some drinks I want to go out
we should smoke a [ __ ] and just grab a
juice take a couple of hits and
celebrate I can't wait to hear all about
this take the hat off immediately pour
some to slap it [ __ ] the [ __ ] out
and I was ordered to take that hat off
to until outside good because I your I
[ __ ] I tried he goes yeah don't ever
ever bring that hat into my [ __ ] bar
again and he was right he was right you
gotta have friends and keep you in line
you know anyway what else you go to the
next one is the bylaw allenge do you
know the balance I remember head back
this kid I do go do you know how it
started he posted a picture and
Instagram of him next to an airplane
like that use like got to head to New
York ow Florida flying private spread
out and then people say out of our
Southwest so that's the initial picture
traveled a Howard press one for growing
up hip hop let's go promise bring you
all the hottest show ever
alright and then someone took a picture
of them inside a plane ah ah come on bro
look so this guy little bow was on my
flight to New York on its gonna impose a
breach of a private jet captain travel
New York today shaking my head Jesus
crying and then it just caused this
whole social network storm where
everyone's posting these pictures but
then they kind of give like a like this
like fake yeah it's fake it's like it
almost looks real and they post a
picture next to it showing what's the
real picture like did you I saw some guy
Joe headed to work things are looking up
and he's driving like a Kia but he wrote
like a resume a sign and I hate it on
there that is a who's this girl holding
up pants and and shoes and then was my
manners push you so that you know flag
Bala Jodo good old on my pants that you
champion in the bow-wow challenge just
focus in pic and then if you there's no
one that knows their hahahahaha this
one's good this guy's at a game but then
did a picture below let you've at the
gate
ah what the [ __ ] that to me I have to
stay in for the back shelf it's so great
this is a whole ton of them dude let me
see more these are great oh he's the
miniature on the hello mom hahaha
hahaha that's genius hello bomb yeah I
don't brag about that that's a great
help [ __ ] great balance edits he did
it on purpose do you believe that not at
all okay not only spit shirt out nope
yeah yeah big wrapper still no he was he
was really big but not banning these
there's a very small show called growing
up hip hop on I asked Jim everybody
relax everybody relax your priorities
are in the wrong place take it from the
old man over here
I've seen people for 23 years chase the
wrong things in this town and I've seen
my culture begin to do the same thing
you know what the thing is was if your
bowel think about it you had this
booming career you're flying you know
private and all that you know and then
he posted a picture you might as well
not impose to pay just post something
promoting your show but then when you
try there's still flats that you're
flying private and you everything's
still good when it's not like I don't
know if that's the way to go but for him
I feel like you just don't want you know
you don't want to look like you've taken
a step back right right you know like
there's a lot there's there's some
comics I see that used to theaters and
maybe in stadiums and now you see about
clubs they don't promote any of those
clubs and dates because it's almost like
again it goes back to what are your
priorities and what you care about and
you know at the end of the day I'm
telling you right now you better be a
person of substance you can hike will
get you a certain distance it will but
you better be just for your own soul and
your own fulfillment doing work you're
proud of move and and and really
developing a skill set I don't care what
it is and let me say something else
about this like globe some Jordan
Peterson on Rogan said something really
awesome if you want to change the world
start by cleaning your own room and
that's a metaphor but it's also literal
mom you can't tell anybody how to live
their life we should keep a messy room
right the idea is worry about yourself
and do one honest thing for yourself
take one act honest action if you're
lost and you think everything sucks take
one honest action well I actually
believe I just believe in a go even if
you don't have the money figure it out
go learn something about something
whether it's in jiu-jitsu class anything
just take that one thing get get in
shape start eating better food any
little thing I swear to god you'll feel
better and it
leads to up to another you don't know
it's angry to say what bum Morales
listen the it's one my favorites was the
the Guy Ritchie episode with Rogen I
love Guy Ritchie's talk about why he
wears a suit because he owns the suit
and they're in America yeah like we have
this bad connotation with suits because
you working nine to five for a man and
he's like nah I dress like this because
I [ __ ] home if I want to own yes
comfortable it's a great conversation
and but you saw my Hollywood so weird
now with like the movies and his movie
just came out to get what's called the
sword the Stone sword in the stone movie
yeah we're not King Arthur's King our
King Arthur I was making this logic bomb
he was talking I'm growing how got hope
it does well did you ask me the right
timing you never know like you just
wanna make great art but now there's
this whole world of money they got to
get the money back he's like you know
I'm on here cuz I'm in just hear how he
wants things to work and then I wake up
someone I see King Arthur's huge flat
like he must feel like ah again it goes
back to hype so and Guy Ritchie's not
you not height right like not a horse
but it's like of course [ __ ]
workhorse he's smart and he's talking
about his King Arthur story and all the
stuff he did and how long it took and
all the stuff he's like you know things
have to line up for things to hit like
you have got the right timing and this
in the summer and they can't really fall
yeah I'll call it a happy accident
because there's so many moving parts and
so many things it's just a bummer man
but a lot of it just goes wah I felt bad
for ya I'm sure he's fine but the feel
that but that has between people and me
my bullet shot like gotta go kinda sucks
that guy J or the same point you know
he's fine he's a hundred million dollar
bank you know you don't realize it that
doesn't mean [ __ ] that's not happiness
happiness like is people approving his
movie this creep this art that form that
took four years to make and he put
everything into four years of his life
just to get approval that people
actually like you thinking about the
money
yeah the money is nothing he's has money
he's financially after his first I'm
sure three milanese all set
Tamil guy who's married to Madonna he's
had at all that stuff doesn't mean it
doesn't matter asking about substance
right you know he's a man of substance
already so that's what I mean by he's
fine well no it goes back to the movie
goes back today about their work right
so so so there is all you have is the
truth right all you have is the ability
to do truthful work and work that make I
don't care
building [ __ ] cabinets I don't care
what it is you know it's it's like what
kind of pride of you taking in the work
you do it whether regardless of what it
is and you know one of the things that
bothers me to be honest with you is that
when soso Brennan sent me this yesterday
was I thought was really cool I'll just
share this with I'm sorry I'm gonna do
this but I think it's I think it's
important I think it's timely and I
appreciate that other dick pic with the
delay it might be so Brendan this is my
brother here Brennan sent me this
he says showed me that he sold out the
Metro Theatre in Sydney ok and it said
well sold out my first theater and then
he said I get the t's just want you to
know brother if it wasn't for you I
wouldn't have any of this in my life and
I showed that to my wife and I said and
of course I appreciate him saying that
but and I showed this to Stevie and I
also but then I said and I am when
people say this I always say that's not
true it's not true like I appreciate say
that but it's not true because I suppose
in this particular business I've been
helpful in kind of like being an example
and maybe you know into giving you
advice but you are the kind of person
that your habit is excellence you are a
[ __ ] grinder you are strategist you
work really hard so I don't I don't
believe that I think you would have
found your way either way because that's
what happens with people who win and
because they're they they have a habit
of excellence and a habit of always
working for what they consider their
truth like what they I know with you I
know that you're not satisfied ever and
you're not going to be satisfied until
you have the set as a comic that you
feel is worthy of being on camera you
know as a special Kerr and then you'll
do that and be on to the next and so
that habit of excellence of course you
have a habit of gratitude I have a habit
of gratitude when you as things are
going well how can you not thank your
friends the people you love the people
that you're on this journey with right
we love being on this today all together
but what what is more more important is
that you know I know you now very well
and I know people like you I know people
rogon I know people that are effective
you can to be successful you find your
way [ __ ] through you would fun sure
people he'll sing tonight and I don't
think it's then that I don't doubt it
I really don't regard my Syrian that you
know I'm saying like - and there's other
uninsured stamps who have started out
there like it's a tough road I know but
you chose to do it you you could've
easily said that's not for me and what
you did is you went I'm gonna do it and
you would have done it regardless of
whether or not I [ __ ] him you know I'm
not writing that [ __ ] for you I don't
think so well okay whatever the case you
know you would have found your way
through no this is gonna hurt I cannot
give you 10% and that was what I was
going to ask for I know you're the
mother's gonna County so if I don't get
a little bit I'll I'll get my beak wet
if somebody's not gonna wear my big eye
I don't know what we're doing my bills
you know I carry my I can't believe
you're not come on straighter that hurts
me that [ __ ] son you gotta go there
home me and Chile goes to Jay can't go
well we're gonna go we're gonna do we're
gonna do ourselves a little fighter in
the kid tour I think there should yeah
we should we need to go to England and I
just an idealist show if I don't see a
finally kid tour in Canada soon you got
a bust
almost slap in the face he's about to
bust you can break into CA and give
everybody beaten listen we need Canada
we might need Ireland we might be the UK
yeah and we might have to do Australia
other we might need Columbia and we
might have to cut Columbia just for a
night maybe you're right three days and
as well Malcolm and we will really do it
with just nothing goes goes Columbia and
every you and me a Miami and then we got
to stop in Miami again necessary
business I for work oh yeah sure
research I'm will you search it get
ourselves a couple cigars cigars
hat nothing wrong shirt with flamingos
on it all we need I'm need I need some
tan lotion
we're having some red apple juice we
haven't female salsa dancer lessons of
course I'm going the UM need a little
Sun lotion yeah it's a piyo juice Dixon
and and I and I hear you and then I'm
gonna need an article season to download
on my phone I'm hot phone we make that
happen to the room in Colombia and
suntan lotion it's strict security it is
pretty wild less not this be real like
cache full of American stone cold cash
yeah are these more is that to direct
now so let me write again sir hot I need
some Sun fellows honey Bahama shirt a
waffle cash that guide be careful now
all right careful and some I get more
from indoors now like I don't know else
I don't want you to use the word course
and I want these are girls who are going
to show us around town that we're both
we're both taking men and I want my wife
to know because she listeners pocket I
know your time up made a million all I'm
looking for is a tour guide in Calamba
lot ass that fake titties full mouth
likes to men by the time I'm having to
reconcile that's good because if she
seem like what's [ __ ] you talking about
we're kidding of course no kids good I
do know the listen we have fun you
actually live from Columbia no one
speaks English
yeah girls only please only women
allowed listen with Louise I popular
hotel daddy issues and who were only
wear heels listen and who aren't gonna
Robin still oh [ __ ] and take it off
that's right now now the woman plays and
call me bobble who plays Pablo's wife in
narcos who I didn't notice first men
date they started making out I saw that
one inch and I was watching with my
wife's head I was like Georgia she's all
kinds of jacked up she's got it she's
blowout I thought you said I went that
our [ __ ] wife the way Sean kissing him
too bro how about the [ __ ] report is
not well yeah hurry [ __ ] she's double
so time children I she's a dirty girl
he's in the old rumpy-pumpy yeah Pulido
cuz that was what happened in the show
what happened he was he was giving it to
her in the old coot oh yeah cue our
annual little [ __ ] ho the what the
Negro whole the Mekong
they grow that's how you say black in
furs we like better name
thank huh I'm not anything no you all
don't you dare until races that's all I
meant
did you know I really I personally want
to I'm not going to be doing I know I'm
fine
that means that mean they grow Negoro
means black it's like he's going in a
black hole go what [ __ ] hole yeah I
know but a girl a hole that's nice a
[ __ ] that's how you say her black
holes yeah this one flower look I'm not
gonna high-five you on that and I want
everybody to know that I am NOT
approving of this and I'm writing a
letter to Steve Harvey hey yeah and he's
gonna send you a [ __ ] memo always
being signature says Negro hole well
alright
I just called an ass I call it a cool
can you just say cool Lulu the Negro
hole cool oh nana hey how do you know
she takes min rumpa uh I think that's
what she was saying in the in the show
what'd she say now he's looking at
Negril know cuz I sorta I got yeah
there's like a beard then Negra Modelo
as well yeah I leave he use it as loud
that's what I said no racism any fact
you guys can say whatever you want but
I'm obviously in a KKK rally over here
and are some I want to apologize we'll
take a what a heaven Korean vessel case
is African here are its Negra Modelo
Legolas thinking of do you feel
traumatized as always races talk or
sambucus not it was like a shower
[Music]
there's no prejudice mark they grow
black there is no prejudice in our at
the fight under kid here
I'm so bad because I didn't miss that
narcos see if anything years you just is
attracted to dark meat as you are to
white meat there is no question about
that
yeah prefer number I vacuum I just the
first yeah okay right sisters like
YouTube by the way just to give you them
hungry is a good hungry uh other
dropping the hostess guys move on yeah
bid
I got a dropping knowledge there's been
I was listening to Sam Harris charles
Murray who's very controversial but a
top scholar I wrote a number of books on
IQ and he's done different studies on IQ
and people have IQs it's a fixed score
and stuff like that and a lot of people
a lot of there's a lot of science that
would point to the fact that IQ is a
very good indicator of not only our
intelligence across the board but your
competency in as an employer and things
like that
here's the problem with measuring
intelligence with a number if you this
is for anybody has a lower cell IQ in
fact their studies for the
you know that say that certain racial
groups because of their environment may
test lower on IQ scores and stuff like
that I have a problem with all of it
only because here's the thing that they
can't understand you know that IQ scores
have been climbing steadily over the
past 200 years and in 1815 the average
IQ score was 70 if you were to score 70
now you would be considered borderline
mentally handicapped why why are human
beings getting more intelligent if you
listen sam harris qualm of course a big
fan of and I love his podcasts and
charles murray there was a mystery there
why is that they know there are certain
things you can point to but in on the
line source in fact there is a reason in
fact joseph heinrich people ask me what
to read all the time the secret of our
success a very important book for
anybody wants to read just hendrik
answers that question what why do you
think it is it's interesting because
cognitively I thought resources maybe
it's easier to access information ah
well although that part of it part of it
they think is because human beings are
very good at downloading cultural
software what makes a smarter isn't
necessarily an increase in our cognitive
ability so children don't actually
necessarily score is that much higher
than certain primates in cognitive tests
and again this can be referenced in just
hundreds book to see whatever success
what makes us smarter is the fact that
we are adaptable and we can learn and
more importantly we can we can
essentially a well adapt but also
assimilate culture and we're really good
at so so if I were to give you a
question on and charles murray uses this
example if i were to give you a question
about a rotating 3d structure if you
gave that to somebody who had never seen
a rotating 3d structure with somebody
thirty years ago hadn't because you
hadn't seen that much it'd be very hard
for you to conceptualize what that even
is now because we're so cynical or hate
it we understand what that being in a
spatial relationship and all that so as
we share information we get smarter so
the IQ scores for all human beings they
keep having to adjust the average
meaning now it's at 100 you keep having
a raise what the what people
going to what the average is going to be
because people on Evers are getting
smarter is it because their brains are
growing no Joseph Henrich and a lot of
his research would point to the fact
that we are just a species that gets
smarter because we learn from each other
and we are getting better at genera
information where evolution yes the
loser and the brain changes itself
everybody the brain is something that
actually grows we can produce more
neurons which they didn't think was
possible the brain does change itself
the brain does grow it's and and so
don't limit yourself I don't give a [ __ ]
who you are don't define yourself it
doesn't mean you can run pumps back in
the NFL be realistic but don't limit
yourself if you have passion for
something you can you can learn it you
can learn it a little that's my little
image dropping knowledge great podcast
today fun pot does very proud of you all
[ __ ] aside very [ __ ] proud of you
for the year selling out that and for
selling out a Theatre in Australia did
you ever think did you ever think that
this [ __ ] was going to happen for you
this fast
no I told my management team and agents
when they booked the Australia toilet
that those venues are too big it's a bad
idea well let's see what happens I think
so it goes Brisbane Brisbane Melbourne
Auckland and Sydney
I think Brisbane Melbourne both almost
sold out to the superior in Auckland's
close to when did you get the idea for a
big ground breakdown I came up with the
idea I came up with a name big brown
side I mean he came up with the news I'm
not looking for it doesn't matter how
many [ __ ] what's that worth who knows
I'm not gonna go to a [ __ ] lawyer I
would never do that no no I don't know
man I think I just want like I was this
I you know I listen podcast all the time
I was like god there's not really I
don't know I got a lot of [ __ ] on my
mind which is the mmm so opinionated I
don't want I didn't want the fine kid
just to be about MMA like I don't want
to just talk about MMA so I was like
yeah I'm gonna be bad just do it it's
really like I still once week see how it
goes and boom boom the big brown
breakdown is a great name for it go
crazy do it when you come up with that
uh-oh with uh with a
Fox I broke down this card form the glow
Shekhawat big groundbait does comes in
hamburger Excel imagine I was gonna John
that fans like don't change it finally a
great a great be free yeah be three but
fantastic yeah man excited but we're
going to be in a Oklahoma Arkansas
border I'm a chair time damn they're
sold out yeah I think it might be sold
out yeah I know that Cherokee Casino
don't [ __ ] around take care have a great
coffee great food James gonna be there
that search just for Oklahoma Mike that
your boys coming me chairman chey shop
for the rest of that Australian tour for
the tickets
t5k Tom everything keep a calm and then
I'm in New York just announced New York
Gotham comedy club on June 22nd ha be
there I'll be there
Brian walsim Tommy Harris not be a god
he's alive big brown breakdown at Gotham
comedy club June 22nd pretty sure in
that because I'm working for boom June
22nd because I'm working for a belt or
for the match Square Garden card I'll be
on Spike TV as well that week I'm in New
York can be good one bigger what does it
say bigger better bigger better banners
it's great what do you got be not a lot
of time off time I'm probably doing
standard besides in LA is going to be in
fact we want to see me I'll be at the
comic store with you do night tomorrow
night tomorrow night when it comes to
and they just do one of my favorite
people I've never met him in person
Nick Kroll eyeliner I literally won my
money no as far as like artist he's won
my hair we got Nick Kroll is gonna be
there we had two big big night Tuesday
night comom excited hey me some time but
I think we're gonna said that project
yeah we're to start that project I'm
gonna be playing tennis I'm going to be
a gentleman boxer and I'll be I'll be
doing a lot of local stand-up love in
writing I'm excited I spend in town my
dogs my kids well yes oh yeah it's don't
need German Shepherd everybody feedback
a calm for everything you've ever needed
we will see you this Saturday of Gloam
Arkansas Cherokee Casino we come in live
live this is the finally kid we're out